لا صوت يعلو على صوت الرصاص عزيزي
الطائرات وهدير الدبابات في المدينه
المتحوله الى ميادين قتال بغت الناس في
اشغالهم وبيوتهم وحاصر الاطفال في المدارس
والمرضى في المستشفيات معالم الماساه
تتعاظم مع كل ساعه من حرب عنوانها
البيانات المتضاربه عن تقدم احد الطرفين
الجيش السوداني بقياده الجنرال عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده
الجنرال محمد حمدان حميتي ويعمق الغموض
خطرا انحدار حرب الاخوه حلفاء الامس اعداء
اليوم الى صراع يستوطن الشوارع والمدن
والولايات وهي جاريه فعلا شرقا في كسله
وشمالا في مروي وغربا في الفاشر ونيالا
حواضر دارفور انها بلاد شاسعه معقده
التشابك القبلي مضخمه
المستنفري لاي شراره في اليوم الثالث على
الارض معارك عنيفه تركزت حول مطار العاصمه
ومطار مروي في سعي محموم للسيطره على
المطارات حيث يتفوق الجيش بسلاح الجو فيما
قوه الدعم السريع بالاليات والمدرعات
الصغيره خفيفه الحركه سريعه الاختفاء وبثت
قوه الدعم صورا قالت انها من داخل مقر
البرهان في مبنى القياده العامه خبر نفاه
الجيش ورد بانه يلاحق من سماه بالمتمردين
الذين يفرون في كل اتجاه ويتحصنون بين
الاهالي وفق بيانه ومع انفجار صراع
الايرادات حربا مخيفه وضع حمايه اخيرا
اطارا لها ابعد من صراع على السلطه عندما
اعلن انه يقاتل ما وصفه بالاسلام
الراديكالي متهما البرهان بانه متطرف يشن
حربا على الديمقرا التي يحميها هو ثم ذيل
قوله بدعوه المجتمع الدولي الى اتخاذ موقف
ورد عليه المعسكر المضاد بتاريخه لقد برز
محمد حمدان دقلو او حمايه ابن لارفور من
حروب الواقع ضد التمرد هناك مطلع الالفيه
قاتل لصالح الحكومه ذات التوجه الاسلامي
مجردا من انتماء سياسي او ايديولوجي انه
تاجر قوه وفق خصومه تعلم الحياه والحرب في
مواضعها لا في المدارس ثم صعدت قواته التي
تحمل اسم الدعم السريع الى مصاف القوى
الشرعيه في زمن الرئيس عمر البشير الذي
اطيح به بتكافل بين حماتي نفسه والمؤسسات
العسكريه اما البرهان وفق مناصري الجيش
فهو الجنرال القادم من قلب المؤسسه مترقيا
اركان جيشا ما عاد يحتمل جيشا موازيا يعصى
على الدمج بطموحات لا حدود لها
تهدد امن البلاد وتجعلها
رهينه الفوضى
علامه ستنتهي الحرب يترقب الجميع جلاء
غبار المعارك لتعرف الدول على اي جنبيها
تميل والغبار يزيد خانقا باعثا الفزعه في
مشهد يختزله سلاح مختلف النشاه والجذر
غامض الوجهه